giggling this is teen Dumbledore that's
right how old are you 20 gigs sorry okay
it does not do to dwell on dreams and
forget to live no is it okay if I just
do Marcia Gay Harden monologue from
Pollak
sure whatever works might work why did
you just say to me pop you want a baby
look at you with your drinking yo
are you ready am I am i ready to play
Albus Percival Wulfric Brian Dumbledore
yes I am did Nick Offerman know the
whole name no no Nick Offerman didn't
know the whole name hmm
just real quick I'm I'm teen Dumbledore
who's playing young man Dumbledore Jude
Law Jude Law yeah that's a that flows it
seriously what is with the wands I mean
what are these like the cell phones of
the Wizarding World you got to call down
a spell away hang on I can't cast
Patronus I've only got two bars
five-foot-ten and some change okay
you know what can I just I got some
pocket whole thing I wanted to try here
and I think it's more on the it's more
on the teen side of things broom broom
Oh what it matters not what somebody is
born but what they grow to be you are
right oh by the way hog horse is lame
and learning is for fools you know what
maybe he's just shaved baby's room it
does not do to dwell on dreams and
forget to live I'm a teenager yeah I
think you got it I think you got plenty
[Applause]
cut the camera good
for I have decided it's something please
don't make me do anything malcolm in the
middle' related
sure no problem and that's what I knew I
had them in the Paula my
[Applause]
you